منعطفٌ جديدٌ تشهدُه الساحةُ اللبنانية عقب ظهورِ بوادرِ انفراجٍ في ملف العسكريينَ اللبنانيين المختطفين لدى تنظيميِ جبهة النصرة وداعش.
المفاوضاتُ التي يقودها المديرُ العام للأمنِ العامِ اللبناني اللواء /عباس إبراهيم/ وتجري بوساطةٍ قطرية باتت أكثرَ جدية في هذه المرحلة ما دفع البعضَ للتكهنِ بقرب اتمامِ الصفقة، بيدَ أن اللواءَ إبراهيم الذي بدا متحفظاً، أكد أن الأمور لم تبلغ خواتيمَها النهائية،
داعياً إلى إبعادِ المِلف عن التداولِ الإعلامي.
وَفق ما سُرب لبنانيا، تشملُ تفاصيلُ الصفقةِ الموعودة الآتي:
- الإفراجُ عن عددٍ من الموقوفين في السجون اللبنانية من بينهم نساء، وأبرزُهم سجى الدليمي طليقةُ زعيمِ تنظيم داعشِ أبو بكر البغدادي، وعلا العقيلي زوجة القيادي في التنظيم أبو علي الشيشاني إضافة إلى أخرى تدعي جمانة حميد.
- وفي المقابل تسلمُ جبهةُ النصرة العسكريين المخطوفين الستة عشر
وبالرغمِ من كلِ التقدم الجاري تلوحُ عثَراتٌ في طريق نجاح الصفقة منها:
- مطالبةُ النصرة بالإفراجِ عن عدد من الموقوفينَ في السجون السورية
- إلقاءُ الأمن اللبناني القبضَ على عدد من المتطرفين الذين يشتبهُ بضلوعهم في تفجيرات بيروت الأخيرة، وهؤلاء بحسب مصادرَ على صلةٍ بالنصرة وداعش.
- كما أن جبهةَ النصرة كانت قد طالبت الأسبوع الماضي بتسليمِها قريتي المَعَرة وفليطة السوريتين لقاءَ الإفراج عن العسكريينَ المخطوفين.
جذورُ عملية الاختطاف تعود إلى أغسطس آب من العام الماضي، أثناء تصدي الجيش اللبناني لمحاولة تنظيمي داعش وجبهة النصرة احتلال بلدةِ عرسال الحدودية شمال شرق لبنان.
التنظيمان آنذاك اختطفا تسعةً وعشرينَ عسكرياً لبنانياً قتلوا منهم أربعةَ جنود في حين بقي خمسةٌ وعشرونَ آخرون قيد الاحتجاز، ستةَ عشر من هؤلاء في يد جبهة النصرة، والتسعة الآخرون يحتجزهم تنظيمُ داعش.
يرى كثيرون أن الجولةَ الحالية من المفاوضات تميزت بواقعيةِ الطرفين وبسرعة إيقاعها، ناهيك عن حاجةِ اللبنانيين إلى تهدئةِ بيتهم الداخلي، بيد أن الحذرَ يبقى وارداً، خوفاً من عودة الأمور إلى نقطة الصفر.